as per the usual arrangement on Sunday
Republicans reached a deal with
Democrats to pass a 1.1 trillion dollar
spending bill that will avoid a
government shutdown through September
here's what's in the bill funding for
Planned Parenthood Obamacare Iran deal
the National Endowment for the Arts and
sanctuary cities here's what's not in
the bill funding for Trump's planned
border wall incredibly the new omnibus
even includes a measure to increase the
influx of temporary workers under h-2b
visas through September but at least
Republicans raised military spending
right that's the take from Speaker of
the House Paul Ryan who has a bad habit
of pulling such gills off with
Democratic help in 2013 Ryan cut a deal
with Senator patty Murray Democrat of
Washington to raise sequestration caps
cut cost-of-living adjustment for
veterans increased taxes and do so in
exchange for empty promises of future
cuts on this bill Ryan brags quote we
have boosted resources for our defense
needs without corresponding increases in
non-defense spending of course
Republicans run both houses of Congress
this time and President Trump is in the
White House but no matter the dreaded
government shutdown has been avoided for
the time being even the defense
increases by the way are about half of
what Trump wanted Republicans caved
again they were elected to overturn
Obamacare they haven't and they won't
even the supposed plan vote this week on
Obamacare repeal does not repeal
Obamacare it were elected to build
Trump's border wall they haven't there
are no immediate plans to do so they
were elected to fund Planned Parenthood
they haven't as bloomberg points out
quote overall the compromise resembles
more of an Obama administration era
budget than a trump one the National
Institutes of Health for example which
he a two billion dollar boost reflecting
the popularity of medical research among
lawmakers the deal includes nine hundred
ninety million dollars for famine aid
along with a 1.1 billion dollar boost
for disaster recovery funds more than 70
anti environmental policy riders in the
bill were defeated
no wonder Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer said quote this agreement is a
good agreement for the American people
and takes the threat of a government
shutdown off the table you know who also
like the deal Nancy Pelosi Trump is now
preparing to push forward the new health
care plan which doesn't repeal Obama
care his aides say he's going to push
for a massive infrastructure spending
plan sometime in the next two or three
weeks Barack Obama would be proud of the
Republicans I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so if all that sounds depressing just
wait for the rest of the show but
actually we will be getting to the White
House Correspondents Dinner which was it
just demonstrates that Trump's luck
definitely extends to his opponents
because his opponents are the dumbest
people alive
the journalists at the White House
Correspondents Dinner made complete
fools of themselves before we get to
that I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at ring comm so most of
the burglaries that happen in the United
States happen in broad daylight with a
burglar ringing your doorbell to see if
you're home and then once they know your
way then they break into the house well
the ring video doorbell means that when
they ring your doorbell and instead of
going to your house it also goes to your
phone that means you can pick up you can
say I'm at home what do you want you can
see who it is at your door ring video
doorbell has been proven to stop
burglaries before they happen by
allowing you to see and speak with
anyone approaching your door using your
smartphone now they have their advanced
motion detection technology to protect
your entire property that's called the
ring of security kit which includes that
ring video doorbell I talked about we
have one installed at our home we have
the ring stick up cam it's a wireless
weatherproof HD camera to keep an eye on
the other parts of your property it is
imperative if you're worried about home
security to get ring okay ring calm /
spend $150 off that ring of security kit
ring calm / Ben my wife is constantly
afraid of a home break-in I'm afraid of
home breaking because I'm public figure
and so that's why we have ring comm also
gives us the ability to see who's at the
front gate before we allow anybody to
come on to the property as opposed to
just an audio doorbell ring calm so I
spend $150 off that ring of security kit
and again it's ring calm / been joined
millions of people who already use ring
calm to protect their home terrific
product okay so the White House
Correspondents Dinner happens over the
weekend and this was from triumphant
moment because well the White House
Correspondents Dinner is going on this
is happening apparently on what was a
Saturday night and it was happening this
is at the same time this is happening
President Trump was giving a massive
rally in Pennsylvania which is really
smart it's really smart and it's really
funny he is a rally at the same time
mocking the members of the press and
we'll start with the members of the
press who made asses of themselves for
eight years they disappeared Obama just
was a good guy why do we need to watch
this guy there's no reason we need to
watch this Obama fellow and then Trump
comes back into power and Republicans
are back in power and suddenly they've
awoken like
the money they have awoken from their
sleep and they've come to revenge
themselves on all things Trump so it
started with Will Ferrell's showing up
at the White House Correspondents Dinner
again
whereas Will Ferrell the last eight
years doing political comedy know where
he played Bush and then he disappeared
because all of the political comedians
just decided it was no longer important
to actually do political comedy for
eight years because Obama was just such
a magnificent fellow
well now Will Ferrell is back imitating
Bush and this time Democrats are doing
the revisionist history where they say
yeah we wish we had Bush back because
Trump is so terrible if you recall they
said the same thing about Reagan with
Bush so every time there's a Republican
president they say the last Republican
president was so awesome
we missed that guy so here's Will
Ferrell doing that routine George W Bush
how do you like me now
yeah the prodigal son has returned you
guys are always sneak up on me with
gotcha questions like why are we going
to war got you why did you not respond
to Hurricane Katrina got you what is
your middle name gotcha this is the
whole routine they did with Bush how
stupid he was had terrible he was again
Obama was president for eight years did
anybody in the media ask him
why did you go to war in Syria gotcha
no nobody asked him that question
because instead of going to war in Syria
are doing anything about Syria he handed
over to the Russians nobody asked Barak
Obama about what he was doing at any
time during his presidency even though
he was a horrible president but Will
Ferrell is back and it's like the
Republicans never left power isn't that
wonderful that wasn't the most offensive
part White House Correspondents Dinner
host Hassan min Hajj they brought out
his Muslim comedian that nobody's ever
heard of because obviously we need a
Muslim comedian not because he's
talented because he isn't but because if
he's Muslim then it shows that
Republicans hate Muslims if they
criticize him so here is here is Hasan
Minhaj blasting Trump it's not bad that
he's Muslim by the way it's bad that
he's a crappy comedian here he is you
know a lot of people told me his song if
you go after the administration it would
be petty unfair and childish in other
words presidential here we go I get why
Donald Trump didn't want to be roasted
tonight by the looks of them he's been
roasting non-stop for the past 70 years
historically the president usually
performs at the Correspondents Dinner
but I think I speak for all of us when I
say he's done far too much bombing this
month
now a lot of people in the media say
that Donald Trump goes golfing too much
that's always like he goes golfing too
much which raises a very important
question why do you care do you want to
do do you want to know what he's not
doing when he's golfing being president
let the man putt putt keep him
distracted teach him how to play Batman
tell him he has a great body for
bobsledding playing tic-tac-toe the
longer you keep him distracted the
longer we're not at war with North Korea
every time Donald Trump goes golfing the
headlights should read Trump golfing
apocalypse delayed take the W this is
great I love this even if you guys groan
I've already hired Kelly and Conway
she's gonna go on TV on Monday and tell
everybody I killed so it really doesn't
matter but I love I love that
everybody's drinking having a good time
this is beautiful you know Donald Trump
doesn't drink right does not touch
alcohol which is oddly respectable let's
think about that that means every
statement
every interview every tweet completely
sober how is that possible okay so he
does I can't imagine why Trump didn't
show up for this and I can't imagine why
people thought this guy was terrible oh
maybe it's because he's awful I mean
just by any objective measure he's awful
at this at least he can say that Will
Ferrell is a talented guy I don't know
where they dug this guy up but this guy
would have bombed and like the local
comedy club and they put him up in front
of the entire nation and he's supposed
to be roasting Trump and then of course
everybody in love said he destroyed
Trump note Trump still president just
ridiculous
and then Samantha B got the most
obnoxious person on cable television
she's in a running gun fight with Trevor
Noah and amy schumer and lena dunham to
be the least funny person in America and
Amy Schumer gets up and she salutes the
press because if there's anybody who
needs saluting it's the press that
wrongly covered this election that
wrongly covered President Obama that
wrongly covered President Bush and that
is now feeding itself for being the
greatest people on planet earth Hera
Samantha be the least funny woman in
America I give her the title narrowly
over Amy Schumer here she goes
much as I might love poking fun at the
media and as much as you all kind of
deserve it sometimes I know your job has
never been harder POTUS has convinced
88% of his fans that you're an enemy of
the people you basically get paid to
stand in a cage while a geriatric
orangutan and his pit mob scream at you
it's like a reverse zoo but you carry on
you dig up misdeeds and fraud by the
powerful you expose injustice against
the weak and you continue to fact-check
the president as if he might someday get
embarrassed
tonight is for you tonight the president
screams at a pen that K teacher is not
in tears okay so they're toasting
themselves because nothing says in touch
with the people cares about to me to the
people like people wearing
thousand-dollar suits and toasting each
other for doing basic journalism which
they ignored for the past eight years
and then the White House Correspondents
Association president got up there and
lambasted Trump to again remember these
are the journalists right these are the
people who are supposed to be honestly
covering this administration do they
think they're going to convince anybody
anyone in America that they are not just
hateful spiteful angry people against
President of the United States and they
do stuff like this or Jeff Mason of
Reuters
who's ahead of WHCA we cannot ignore the
rhetoric that has been employed by the
president about who we are and what we
do freedom of the press is a building
block of our democracy undermining that
by seeking to D legitimate journalists
is dangerous to a healthy Republic so
where was this guy when Barack Obama was
sticking the DOJ on The Associated Press
where was he when when the when brocco
bomb was directly attacking Fox News and
taqueria where was he when Barack Obama
was using the DOJ to target Fox News is
James Rosen and by the way actually
prosecute journalists I mean prosecute a
buncha journalists for supposedly where
was he he was gone right so for eight
years it was as though Barack Obama
wasn't president it just disappeared
from memory there's a line in Field of
Dreams in which a very lucky character
gets up and talks about how there was
Eisenhower Republicans there was
Eisenhower and then there was there was
there what was it he said something like
there was three terms of Nixon and then
there was just skipped right onto
Reagan's hip the Carter years or skipped
the Nixon years or whatever it was okay
that's actually what Democrats do they
think that there were two terms of Bush
and then eight years just disappeared
down the toilet and then there was Trump
they just went straight from Bush to
Trump Obama didn't exist in the middle
and then the capper of all of the
Samantha be again the least funny person
woman in America she gets up there on
CNN and she's asked as though she's a
serious person on State of the Union
Jake Tapper who I generally like his
report
a per ask Samantha B what she thinks of
the current state of the country and she
says she dropped this aw inspiringly
stupid line Hillary Clinton's semantics
me no you did did you I don't know
flattering I didn't know that there was
a Samantha bee problem but let me read
part of it to you the Democratic Party's
problem in the age of Trump isn't really
Jimmy Fallon who you had criticized and
others who criticized for being too soft
them from it's probably Samantha bee not
be alone of course but the entire
phenomenon the she embodies the rapid
colonization of new cultural territory
by an ascendant social liberalism first
what's your response and second of all
how does it feel to be you know the face
of the problem oh my god my name was in
an article um it's me it's not racism
it's just me no you know what I'll pay
for all I'll wait for all that evidence
to roll in and then all then I'll make
up my mind after that just because there
was no backup it was just you know it's
one person's opinion but it wonderful
lap one wonderful is a meson action but
let me ask you let me ask you a question
does he have a larger butt and you've
addressed this on your show so remove
yourself from it does he have a point
about smug liberals I'm not talking
about you by debate but does but is
there a smug liberal but I know that is
something that I can't really I mean I
can't take responsibility for the way
the election turnout I just absolutely
don't know well I can't is there as much
you told another Johnson
I guess I'm s you know I don't I don't
think there is like I do the show for me
and for people like me and I don't
really care how the rest of the world
sees it quite there's no mug liberal
problem I do the show for people like me
and people like me but there's no smug
liberal problem I don't care what the
rest of the world thinks there's no smug
liberal problem you just described the
smug liberal problem you do a show for
you and people like you and you don't
care what anybody else things because
you think that you are the repository of
all knowledge wisdom and decency in the
United States but there's no smug
liberal problem no what we have here is
a smug liberal comedienne self-aware in
its problem that's what we have here and
this is the problem with the left and
this is why Trump is so ever-loving
lucky he's the luckiest man in America
because the left is so smug
the left is so terrible and they can't
even see
it themselves so Trump goes out there
any campaigns and he's talking to people
he thinks are sort of the Forgotten
people the people that Samantha B just
said she doesn't care about they don't
watch her show you know those people
Trump talks to those people then he says
look at that smug liberal in every goes
yeah you know why because he's right
because they are smug leftists that is a
smug leftist she is awful
she's sitting there in her expensive
clothing on an expensive set with Jake
Tapper and before that not an expensive
set at the White House Correspondents
Dinner with the people who are the
repositories of knowledge remember when
reporters in the old movies they used to
be people who are like the battered
Derby hats and they were the men of the
streets he changed smoked and then went
out there and they reported on things
that were happening on the ground now
they go to the White House
Correspondents Dinner and there were
tails in a tie and Samantha bee wears
her very fancy suit and they go out
there and they jabber about how what
wonderful people they are they become
celebrities in their own right and this
is what Trump hit I want to get through
Trump's response because it was top
notch Trump in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our friends our
new sponsors over at Skillshare so I'm
someone who constantly loves to learn I
love learning I love taking classes it's
something that I really enjoy and in
today's modern economy you have to be
broadening your skillset all the time
one of the big problems with the economy
is people get stuck in their skill set
and they don't try to broaden it that's
what skills share calm is for Skillshare
calm allows professionals to get a leg
up at work because when you subscribe
then you are able to get some new skills
added to your resume they have these
45-minute classes that 15,000 of them in
design business and more you can learn
everything from logo design to social
media marketing to street photography
this entire set of skills and then if
you're bored of business guilting you
can join IG I took a watercolor class
yes believe it or not I took a
watercolor class at Skillshare comm one
of the most popular actually super cool
stuff they have classes ranging from
email marketing and social media
marketing and SEO to illustration
watercolor and calligraphy it's just a
place to learn and it's a place to
broaden the skills that you need skill
share comm slash capiro and if you go to
Skillshare comm slash capiro you can get
a free month of unlimited access for
free use that slash up here with the end
Skillshare comm slash appear again
15,000 classes and design business and
more super cool site the classes are
top-notch easy to use friendly and real
educational and you're not wasting your
time because everything is very
condensed so that you gain a new skill
every time you take one of their
45-minute courses again in Skillshare
dot-com / Shapiro great site one month
unlimited access for free when you use
that back slash Shapiro okay so Trump
responds to the White House
Correspondents Dinner with this rally
very smart he ignores all of the
journalists feeding each other and
patting each other on the back and he
was just going to go there and they were
going to make fun of him and there were
going to be pictures of him looking sour
so smart of him to skip it I think it's
a dumb event and so instead he went to
this rally and here is him knocking the
media a large group of Hollywood actors
[Applause]
and Washington media
our consoling each other in a hotel
ballroom in our nation's capital right
now and that is why people like Trump in
a nutshell that is why people like Trump
and people also like Trump because
trumpian is on Face the Nation over the
weekend and here is Donald Trump
catering to his crowd by basically
ripping on John Dickerson who is the
host of Face the Nation you know it's
very funny when the fake media goes in
you know which we call the mainstream
media which sometimes I must say is you
but when the making personally are your
show I love your show I call it - Face
the Nation but you know your show is
sometimes not exactly correct and
everybody on the right loves is of
course as well they should because the
media are a bunch of leftist trolls who
hate President Trump and hate the right
now the reason the left is scared of
Trump is because something Reince
Priebus said over the weekend here's
Reince Priebus talking about how the
White House considered the changing and
changing libel law changing the First
Amendment of the Constitution this is
why the left looks at people like us you
know people who say look the media is
full of it and they say why aren't you
scared of Trump - I mean Trump is the
one talking about changing the First
Amendment change the libel laws that
would require as I understand it a
constitutional amendment is he really
going to pursue that is that something
he wants to pursue I think it's
something that we've looked at and how
that gets executed or whether that goes
anywhere it's a different story but when
you have articles out there that have no
basis or fact and we're sitting here on
24/7 cable companies writing stories
about constant contacts with Russia and
all these other matters I think the
president should be overall soother
attaching stories I think I think that I
think that newspapers and news agencies
need to be more responsible with how
they report the news I believe that part
is true of course newspapers and news
agency should be more responsible but
this idea that you're going to revise
the First Amendment that does scare
people and it should scare people
because if Barack Obama we're saying it
everybody on the right would be going
nuts again this is my shoe on the other
foot test if Reince Priebus right now
we're rahm emanuel and who are saying
the same things we should be happy or
would you be sad today and the answer is
you would be sad today because this is
not something the president should be
saying but this is something I want
a little bit more about if you subscribe
so go over to daily wired.com right now
get a subscription for $8 a month $8 a
month will get you the rest of the show
live you can watch it live you can also
be part of the mailbag that we do on
Thursdays here on the show lots of
goodies coming also if you're an annual
subscriber then you also get a free copy
of Jeremy borings the Royal fictional
film set on the southern border all
about people using the southern border
as a thoroughfare for drugs and human
trafficking a really really good movie
you can go check it out over there or if
you don't want to become a subscriber
right now or you just want to listen to
the show a little later iTunes or
SoundCloud if you are listening on
iTunes
please set please give us a rating and
leave a review we always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the United States
[Music]